and as we head into Mother's Day weekend
important to remember that every mom has
a different story as to how she became a
mother 80's out reporter Brian will
takes us through one mom's journey of
adoption and now hit has changed her
life
when I met my husband in 2009 the first
thing I said when I met him was hey I'm
planning on being a foster parent so if
you're not into it like don't take this
any farther he was like or I guess we're
good Ali Caliendo and her now husband
Terry became foster parents the same
year they got married in 2012. a year
later a young boy named Anthony came
into their life we said if we did have
our own child we would name him Anthony
and so when I first met Anthony it was
just like meant to be I felt immediately
connected to him he was this adorable
five-day-old baby who had same cute nose
after a few years of fostering Anthony
they finally adopted him the road hasn't
always been easy but it's been worth it
when you decide to Foster and especially
when you decide to adopt you have to
make space for all the adults in the
child's life so we have space here for
Anthony's original mom and we talk about
her we acknowledge and honor her we miss
her
and so it's complex and it's okay that
it's complex and now 10 years later if
people want to adopt they should
definitely try
and I think this is a really great
choice
it's absolutely the best choice that
we've ever made and I would encourage
others to consider it as well for us
Mother's Day is is complicated and we
want to include all the moms in your
life love you buddy
[Music]
[Applause]